usually creativity is the product of one
or two or possibly three Minds working
together in the Arts mostly probably one
but in science what has happened is
because of the big money and Prestige
that goes with enormously expensive
equipment research papers now have as
many as a thousand names attached to
them but Rutherford's paper in 1911 had
only one name on it that of Rutherford
that was a different era in which people
could think freely but nowadays the
pressures for conformism come from the
huge hierarchy of Science and it's been
argued I think persuasively that an
enormous number of truly creative
insights happened in science Across The
Sciences in the early part of the 20th
century and that we've had a regression
since really big breakthroughs in how we
think about the world and the cosmos
have not been happening on the same
scale partly because of this need for
always to be in collaborative
groups